[Music]
let's go to jessica in denver hey
jessica what's happening
hi dr dalony how are you
good how are you just couldn't be having
more fun
okay
so i have a question for any time
somebody starts a call with
okay
it's usually a good one
yeah i um
so here it is um my son's father and i
um decided to separate when he was six
months when my son is six months okay
and now he's 10 months so at that point
at six months he moved out of the house
and
we find ourselves on spending a lot of
time together we all divorced
no we weren't married um we had been
together for about um six years lived
together for four of those years
um so we never were legally married um
to just
cohabiting
and
we decided why'd y'all break up
so there's a
a number of things but i think the three
um events that just
i couldn't come back from were
the biggest one was i got really bad
postpartum depression afterwards and i
just didn't feel supported
by him
one of the times he actually
made a comment once that
i was weak like a weak mom and that
really
like hit me so hard i remember just like
feeling like a punch to my stomach
because i was feeling weak and i was
feeling like um like i wasn't a good mom
so when he
told me those words
i like went into my closet and just
cried
and
he seen me crying and he never like he
didn't say anything to me he actually
said something about um
like stop crying i'm not gonna feel bad
for you because you're crying and
i think that was a turning point for me
because i um
had thoughts of
not being worthy like not being like my
son deserves a better mom
so
the next day after that happened
i
i realized that those thoughts just were
so extreme like i have never
had thoughts like that so i reached out
to a therapist
and
um yeah so i started seeing a therapist
and the other event that was pretty
significant um
was
in december
of 2019
um
he
was unfaithful
he was going to
um get some like massages at a
like a massage parlor place
and i found out about those and um
so just there was no trust
either
like i got a massage yesterday are you
talking about like yeah but these were
yeah these were like happy ending
massages ah okay they were sexualized
massages okay yeah okay and um he like
he told me about them and so there was
no trust and then i think the last um
the last thing that i can
say that
really just like we tried everything to
be together
was couples therapy so i have started my
own individual therapy he started his
individual therapy
and we seeked out a really good couples
therapist and we had been going to some
sessions and in one of those sessions he
decided to just walk out like he was so
upset and he walked out of the session
and i thought he went to go get a
breather but when i looked we were at
home
doing on a video call but when i looked
out the window he had actually left yeah
and
to me that was so rejecting
so
after that i told him i'm still willing
to do couples therapy but you have to
schedule the next one and he just never
did so we were both just full of
resentment
and
couldn't stand each other anymore like
he had been sleeping on the couch for
over a month and a half before we
separated
and we talked and both came to the
decision that it just was not working
for us that we could not
be living together anymore yeah so here
so here you're here now you got a 10
month old
and yeah
i'm going to make a guess i'm going to
make a guess
y'all aren't broken up but you're broke
we really are we've actually discussed
not
getting back together anymore um we
we've both um decided that and
so recently he invited
us to california with him
and i really want to go i was excited
and i mentioned it to my mom and she
actually
said
she made a comment about how i am
setting a bad example for my son
that i'm teaching him what relationships
are like and a wrong way because we're
not together and we don't plan on being
back together and but i'm pretty much
going to scar him
so my question to you was
am i setting a bad example for my son
like should i not be spending as much
time with his son being that we don't
plan on getting back together
i don't believe you that you're not
planning on getting back together
that's just me
um have you all okay so you all broke up
um four months ago i guess five months
ago is that right yes yeah have you all
slept together in that five months
yes
have you all gone we haven't in the past
like three months two months uh
okay great congratulations
have you ever gone to dinner or coffee
or when he comes to see his child do
y'all
do you just go to
yeah yeah
i don't believe you is what i'm saying
that's not a bad thing i still am your
friend and i would still hang out too
i just don't believe you and i think
somewhere in there
y'all got crossways y'all got sideways
and he didn't know how to
handle being a new dad and it scared the
crap out of him
and
postpartum depression is a
just nightmare
and he didn't have the tools to navigate
that and said stupid things
and he's probably doing his own crap
and he was unfaithful and and and and my
guess is
you've got challenges too is that fair
are you alive
yes yes i am you are i am too that's
welcome to the a lot club
and so here's what i'm thinking
um i'm thinking that this is a tough
season and it's frustrating and it's
been really peaceful
to
uh not have to deal with that and you
still love this guy a lot
and or you're connected to this guy that
doesn't mean you have to be married to
him it doesn't mean blah blah but i
think that there is still a part of you
that's not fully done here here's where
the challenge is for your son
it's the sun right i just made that up
it's the sun yes that's the time okay
and again this is putting a lot on a 10
month old which isn't isn't fair
but over time
there's always this childhood fantasy
that my parents will get back together
at some point
and often and this is with a little bit
older kids
they will do whatever they can to try to
make that to facilitate people coming
back together
and that's not a burden that a child
is designed to carry should ever have to
carry it's
unfair
and the other side of that is
when
um
when two adults separate and there's
kids involved and they act like adults
and they treat each other with dignity
and they treat each other with respect
they make the best of an awful situation
then um that's better for kids
what you have to decide is where your
relationship is if you go to a on a trip
to california with him
you all end up being together you know
this he knows this everybody knows this
you know who else knows your mom knows
this
and now america knows this
and so
i i want you to be honest with yourself
about why you're going
is there a part of you that hopes he
calls and or why y'all are on the way to
california it's like hey i've been i've
been in counseling and i'm sorry for the
things i said
there's a i guarantee you there's a part
of you that really hopes that that
conversation happens
and you may have learned some things in
counseling that you hope he asks about
so you can tell him am i am i tell me
i'm way off and say dylan you're an
idiot or am i right
i um
i enjoy his company a lot so you enjoy
his competition
okay so jessica what would he what would
it take what would he have to say
like he calls you and says i'm coming
over this morning
what would he say to you and you were
like all right i'm all back in
i can feel it on you through the phone
that you are one centimeter from being
all back in but he just has to do a
couple things what are those things
i um
no i just don't think that it would work
out i mean it's just the type of person
that he is
um i know i know all that i know all
that and you've you're that's awesome
what would he have to say
for you to be like all right i'm back
and that he's willing to do i knew
i knew
anything he was thinking
yes i knew it though i knew it so here's
the thing
here's where your mom is correct
there is going to be relational modeling
and if your son learns
that there will always be that women
will hang on and hang on and hang on and
hang on and dad can leave and do
whatever dad wants to do
and then swoop back in then swoop back
out
and mom is going to continue to hang on
and hang on and hang on you are correct
there will be a modeling that's going on
about this is how relationships work
your son is not going to listen to you
as much as he's going to watch you he's
not going to listen to dad as much as he
watches dad
the other side of that is
i think that your relationship is still
salvageable as crazy as that sounds
i don't know him i'd have to talk to him
and he's obviously working through some
demons he's got some stuff that he's
gotta gotta navigate
but i don't think the whole thing's over
i do think while you are in limbo land
it is not smart for you to treat him
like a boyfriend
okay
and here's the other can i say something
scary
because you've been through a lot
i don't think
you are broken or weak or dysfunctional
or not a strong powerful single mom
if you sit down and exhale and drop your
shoulders and say holy smokes i still
love this guy
and he did all these things and i still
have feelings for him
i don't think any of that stuff is bad
or
wrong but i think you've got to make
peace with i am not going to be with him
therefore i'm not going to be in
communication with him i'm not going to
go on dates with him i'm not going to
sleep with him i'm not going to fill in
the blank with him i have to move on
with my life we will be connected
forever because we share a child and
we're going to be adults but there is
going to come a day that he calls and
says hey me and my girlfriend are coming
over to pick up our son
and that's going to be
one of those moments we can't breathe
and so i think it's about being honest
with where you actually are it sounds
like y'all are on a break the way you
describe him the things he did yes he
was a scumbag yes he said stupid stuff
yes he was unfaithful absolutely
but you still have feelings for him in a
major way and you either need to cut
ties and move on
or you need to sit down with him and be
honest about here's i'm still here i'm
still in this thing it's the limbo land
that's killing you and so here's the
second thing your mom was right about
but in in not the right not a normal way
what's going to be really tough for your
son
is the absorption
of chaos
of your anxiety
your frustration relationally
your pain
and if you're not whole and well and
doing the things and you are you're in
counsel you are working hard i'm so
proud of you it's incredible so proud of
you
but if you are playing ping pong with
your heart with his dad
that's what your son will absorb
does that make sense yeah yeah that
makes sense
and so i want you to have some hard
conversations with your own heart and
with yourself
and truly mind yourself if you still got
your therapist do it with them
if you have full trust with him full
trust with him why do you think he
i may finish my sentence here and then
i'll
why
you've got to be honest with yourself
about the status of this relationship
because it feels like there's a
dot-dot-dot after this last breakup
why do you think he invited you to
california
he tells me that he wants to spend time
with um our son more
and um
you don't believe him well
you don't believe him why do you think
he invited you i don't care what he said
why do you think he invited you
um i think so that we can
act like a family yeah
you can play family
and it's super cool to play family is it
going to his family going to visit
friends or family of his no no just um
going to san diego it's a vacation huh
yeah it's so fun to play family
and then
he can come back to
denver and you go back to doing all of
the work
night and day and he can live his life
and then when he wants to play family
then he gets to
yeah and that's not fair for you and
that's not fair for that baby and it's
not fair for him
yeah you're right
is that fair i know it's not like your
mom and i just got weird for everybody
right
that's exactly what what she told me
so
she's really going to enjoy listening to
this
no
jessica let me tell you this
you're worth your needs being met
you're worth getting to the bottom of
why you're a lot why you're hard in
relationships
and i love that you've been reflective
enough to deal with that i've had to
deal with it too
yeah
i love that you love your baby and you
want him around his dad i hope you never
ever lose that
yeah and i love the fact that you still
love
i really do
but you're gonna have to make some hard
decisions about what the end of a
relationship means for real
or if you want to sit down and be
vulnerable and say hey you've hurt me in
really bad ways
and i still love you
and if you will x y and z i'm still
willing to be all in or not
but you've got to put some periods at
the end of some sentences so you can
start writing new ones for you and your
son
yeah so because i did make a comment
about us being in limbo once and he said
um
he said you're in limbo i know what i
want
and was it you and i do i feel like i'm
the one that's in limbo like i don't
know yeah you do know if i can trust him
yeah oh he said he wants you
yeah he said he he said you're the one
that's in limbo but when i when we've
talked in the past when i've told him
well these are my niece this is what i
need from you
he's not willing to do him he's like
that's too much
and i'm like okay well
then he's answering your question for
you yeah yeah he's answering your
question
i will tell you that um
infidelities you know no good no bueno
that's that's easy
i know lots of people who've got up and
walked out of
counseling sessions before and that
doesn't mean they're evil people that
means their body say i can handle this
right now
yeah
and it could be stuff as far back as
childhood it could be stuff as far back
as mom and dad it could be all over the
place um i know lots of people who did
not handle do not handle postpartum well
does that excuse it no
it means they are uneducated
scared terrified children who now have a
child
right yeah does that excuse what they
say no does that make the pain any less
no
but i know people who find themselves
relationally in situations where they
are out of tools
and well one time i actually offered one
of your episodes to him i said hey will
you listen to this um
he is giving advice to a husband
who has a wife who has postpartum
depression because i think i have
postpartum depression
and his response was
um
he said
really like you don't think i'm doing
enough for you already
and it just shattered me like i have no
words because tears just started
flooding through
because unlike it it would have been a
15-minute clip that you could have
listened to
that explained exactly what i needed
from him you're correct
that's it would have been 15 minutes and
explained it
and
some men hear
hey i want you to listen to this other
guy
and he's going to tell you how to be
more of a man for me
and
does that mean it's wrong i mean it's
right that he responded that way no
but i also want to be in pathetic and
understand how he may have heard that
here's an obnoxious can i be obnoxious
for a second here's an
obnoxious other side to that
what if he saw some woman in the mall
and he said
that's that's the body i'm looking at
that's the one i was thinking of for you
go talk to her about how her workout and
and diet program is
right and you'd be like how about i drag
you into the parking lot run over you
with the car right
and so
um
sometimes we hear things in ways that
aren't really what the what you intend
but that's how they come across
and it that depends on a million again
you run up with a bunch of tools
if he can't hear the the episode okay
that's great i'm not for everybody
maybe you write down on a piece of paper
with bullet points
here's some things that um i heard from
a mental health guy
that would really be helpful here
or you take what i said and you write
down bullet points and then you
translate them to here are some things
that i need here's some different ways i
can say what i need
and he's going to have to grow up and
know that if somebody loves you if
you're
if the person you're in love with tells
you here's how you can best love me it
doesn't mean that you're an idiot that's
actually the greatest gift one person in
an intimate relationship can give to the
other is to be explicit on here's my
needs
and if if somebody ever has the courage
to tell you their needs and you take
that personally come on man
be better than that
say thank god
now i don't have to really try to read
your mind anymore and it's not a
statement on you failed or you're a
[ __ ] it's just that your person you
love told you hey actually here's what i
need
um
and by the way those needs will change
over the course of your relationship
you're one you're five you're 10 you're
20 whatever and it's man if you find
somebody that will just tell you what
they need oh my gosh it's so great and
i'll be honest the times my wife has
told me that when i was especially when
i was younger it crushed me i thought oh
what a loser i am what a failure i am
and then my shame shot out and i started
reacting like a child i would be silent
for three days or be grumpy or have an
attitude problem because i was an
immature idiot and so
um i don't think you're done
i don't do i think this relationship can
work if y'all both wanted to yes does it
look great right now no
i don't think it's smart to go play
family in san diego though i don't think
that
i don't i think you'll need to sit down
and have a hard direct conversation and
then you have to make some grown-up
decisions
and that's gonna be hard
thanks for calling jessica let us know
in a couple of weeks in a couple of
months how things are going and we'll
walk alongside with you this whole way